Aberdeen is 500 miles from Westminster
the oil and gas capital of Britain and
in recent years it's seen boom bust and
brexit you know it's a pretty gloomy day
here in Aberdeen and in many ways that's
a reflection on how the economy has been
here in the last few years a slump in
the global oil price saw investments
pulled here and a lot of jobs were lost
- and there are fears that brexit could
make matters worse it's the start of a
long journey for me to discover what
people really think about brexit and it
begins here a small shop owned by Zoe
James in the heart of Aberdeen this is
fantastic
thank you very much so this is all this
is how long have you had this place four
and a half years we opened in November
2014 yeah I think that we've kind of
lost our way a bit and I think we should
be more self-sufficient and depend on
ourselves how do you feel about the way
that brexit has panned out I'm very
frustrated I have a huge amount of
sympathy for Theresa May I think I I
wouldn't necessarily have voted for
Whidden but it that doesn't change the
fact that she's taken on an impossible
task and she will never be thanked for
it
there are six million small businesses
in the UK all pretty keen to find out
how brexit might affect them so I've
come to chat to Craig will ox who owns
this bookshop how do you feel about the
way that the brexit process has been
dealt with by by politicians to be
honest I think when the the Vorta came
to me initially and reached sided on you
know point to the plexus aid I think I
think there was a lot of surprise
throughout the world that we've done
that you know I felt I sentiment
embarrassment that we were doing this
and the whole process since then if
anything is this mid mid to me as a
British person Scottish person a bit
more than vilest I wish you know my
heart of hearts that weren't doing it
but I guess people have voted for its or
not got much choice in the matter but no
it's not affected me personally or my
business massively no so fix it is there
but life goes on not everyone is taking
brexit so seriously we saw that photo
opportunity she went on then last year
comedians like vladimir McTavish are
having a field day at bricks it's
expense with no one in control brexit
the unlikely ingredient to a Saturday
night out
at least the time we just need to accept
there was a bad idea
if you go back me beg them for
forgiveness definitely go to a scientist
get a time machine go back in time and
tell everyone really what brexit is all
about and then people would vote
accordingly and we wouldn't be where we
are right now I think we should just
forget that it ever happened I'm leaving
up a team to head south into the
northeast of England on the train I meet
Hillary race and manager in the NHS who
voted remain have you think this story
will end
have you the brexit story will a you
know like five ten years and we go God
member brexit yeah personally I hope
that I mean you know I still still would
like to think that you don't if we don't
not just have to go with that there's
nothing you know the people voters don't
be that bad though Michael it might be
it might not be that bad 250 miles south
of Aberdeen is Newcastle and here
they're watching brexit really closely
because a No Deal brexit according to
business leaders could affect the
northeast economy more than anywhere
else in the UK and remember the story of
brexit here in the Northeast
was it the vast majority of people here
voted to leave the EU how did you vote
in the referendum May I wouldn't leave
are you happy how it's going not
depressing you having a good breakfast
no what do you think should happen then
just well the councillor demoralizing
would you be happy to extend if it meant
that we got a better deal I'd be happy
to extend it infinitely to be honest not
leave yes
I'm heading along the Northumberland
Coast to the port of life
one of the biggest sticking points in
brexit negotiations has been how Britain
will trade after brexit and ports across
the country are watching those
negotiations very closely but one or two
of the potential in with investors to
the port of perhaps waiting to see what
happens with practices so we need as
British ports is for that uncertainty to
to be concluded and we can go on to
continue to do the vital role we do for
the economy but also we add that extra
layer of uncertainty don't with it not
only do we need to solve the uncertainty
surrounding brexit generally but when on
earth we're gonna leave well that's
right and it is not just about whether
we have tariffs or not it's just knowing
what that final conclusion is and is it
gonna be delayed for one month two and
three months to two years who knows
the final stop on this brexit journey is
Torquay the English Riviera town that
turned its back on Europe and voted leaf
I think it's disgraceful and I think
what'll happen is is that come the next
general election I think their votes are
going to be majorly down Jackie hopper
is getting tired of waiting for brexit
how do you feel about it dragging on for
another few months even at end of the
year
[Applause]
and Dolby swapped her teaching job for a
taxicab a few years ago how would you
sum up brexit in a word just I mean hey
only and add one yeah
disappointing why because nothing's
happened it's been three years and
nothing's happened and I just feel like
it's all internal politics got nothing
to do what the British people want it's
funny though isn't there and because
Torquay in this area voted quite heavily
to leave do you think that that was a
mistake
do you think we might see some negative
effects yes I think I was I was for
leave originally but if there was
another vote now I think I would
definitely vote stayed mainly because I
realized that the trouble in the hassle
is taking just today
our journey from north to south has
revealed a nation left looking on
powerless to do anything about brexit
those pulling the strings now the
decision-makers the politicians still
left clambering to find a way out yet
haven't quite managed it Nick Martin Sky
News